اذا مشاهدينا وصلت الرساله ولنبدا فك
الشيفره في عالم التجسس لا باس ان نطلق
العنان قليلا لجيمس لكن لنعد الى العهد
القديم ونرى كيف تفنن العملاء السوريون في
اساليب التجسس الرسائل المشفره حشره
اليعسوب التي استخدمتها الاستخبارات
الامريكيه كجهاز للتنصت وايضا جذع الشجره
ازرار الخميس وحتى كعب الحذاء هذا صنعته
الاستخبارات السوفيتيه لمراقبه
الدبلوماسيين الامريكيين ولا ننسى القطه
المتجسسه بعد الحرب البارده زرعت واشنطن
في اذنيها ميكروفون للتجسس على السفاره
السوفيتيه في امريكا انذاك تطورت الوسائل
من الحشره وحتى الوصول الى هذه الحمامه
وتبدو مثل الطيور الحقيقيه بل وتتطابق
حركتها مع الحقيقيه بنسبه 90% صوتها
الخافت للغايه يصعب اكتشافها من قبل
الانسان والردات تحاكي الحمامه ايضا
المسيرات في حركه الخفقان لاجنحه الطائر
للتحليق والهبوط والانعطاف في الهواء حمام
الصينيه بالمناسبه وصلنا الى التجسس
السيبراني وهو الاحدث الان اقمار التجسس
غزت الفضاء البحر والسماء ولا شك هواتفنا
المقاله لكن ان يكون التجسس عبر حديقه
فهذا غير مالوف نعم مشاهدينا انها الصين
تجاوزت انشطتها الحدود حديقه صينيه مزخرفه
في قلب الحديقه الوطنيه في واشنطن الامر
يبدو طبيعيا كمشروع تجاري بل وشجع السلطات
الامريكيه لجذب مزيدا من السياحه للعاصمه
ليكتشف لاحقا ان الحديقه هذه ستمتلئ
بتماثيل وهياكل وابراج ترتفع 70 قدما ستضع
بشكل استراتيجي في واحده من اعلى النقاط
في واشنطن وعلى بعد مليم فقط من مبنى
الكابيتال تذكرت واشنطن حينها ابراجه
هواوي التجسسيه فقتلت مشروع الحديقه في
مهده
هذه الحديقه مشاهدينا ايقظت المسؤولين
اللي تتصق وجهه نظرهم مع المخاوف
المتسارعه في صفوف الامن الامريكي القومي
من وصول بيانات حساسه لبكين خصوصا وانا لا
احد يضمن الصين بضرباتها الخفيه والمفاجئه
ولذا قد لا يحتاج الامر هنا سياسه تقليم
الاظافر بل البتر وهذا ما شدد عليه ساس
امريكيون بعد الكشف عن التحقيق دعينا لحظر
شركه هواوي نهائيا نذكر بما قاله مايك
بومباي وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه السابق في
يوليو علق على تقرير فوكس نيوز الذي
تحدثنا عنه بتغريده وقال انه هواوي اي
انها دخلت البوابات وهي ليست سوى وسيله
تجسس صينيه ودعم بومبايو لحظر الشركه واخذ
واخذ تهديداتها على محمل الجد السنتر
الامريكي ايضا تساءل مستنكرا لماذا نثق
التكنولوجيا الصينيه سيما وان الجميع يعلم
انها تهدف للاساءه لامريكا
السنتر دعى ايضا لحظر جميع الشركات
الصينيه مثل تيك توك ودي جي اي وايضا على
راسها طبعا هواوي الان وبينما المنطاد لا
يزال يحلق في الاجواء الامريكيه خارج عن
السيطره اشتدت لهجه التصريحات الامريكيه
وتحديدا من الجمهوريين الذين ينتقدون
باستمرار لينا بايدن مع الصين طبعا على
عكس ترامب السنه في لجنه القوات المسلحه
تعامل الفانتاجون مع الحادثه بالفشل في
التعامل مع اختراق السياده الامريكيه
بينما وصف رئيس مجلس النواب الجمهوري كاظم
ما فعلته الصين بالواقع والمزعزع
للاستقرار وطلب من بايدن عدم التزام الصمت
وبالمناسبه حذر مكارسي الصين قبل ايام من
انها لم تستطيع منعه اذا اراد زياره
تايوان